I wanted to ask you first. Since this is an English learning magazine,...
...I would like you to explain a bit, like you know, really simple like...
...maybe kind of in half a minute or 1 minute.
OK.
Can you do that?
Great!
Great.
Yeah.
So I wrote this book, "What I Wish I Knew When I Was 20".
It's initially inspired by my son who was going off to college.
And the theme of the book is that problems are opportunities.
The bigger the problem, the bigger the opportunity.
And the book is about how you actually make things happen,...
...how to challenge assumptions, break the rules, make your own luck,...
...all the things you need to know to actually make your ideas come to life.
OK great, and then so did you actually give this book to your son?
I did. This book came out on his birthday. Can you believe that?
The book came out on his birthday, just by accident.
Really?
The week he turned 20, the book came out.
Wow.
Isn't it wonderful? Yes, it was.
Then of course that is a problem for what was I gonna do for his 21st birthday?
Alright.
I've made it bigger and bigger, right there.
OK. And then what kind of comment did you hear first?
"Oh, that was horrid". No, I'm kidding. I think he's very proud.
He's really excited that the book is so popular here in Japan.